KKBOX was founded in 2004
We started off using cloud technology
to provide a legally authorized
music streaming service
With the support of record companies,
musicians
and partners from the music industry
We've become a mainstream music provider
for online listeners
We believe music makes our lives better
That is why we strive to provide
an even better music listening experience
so that music can be affordable
enjoyable and accessible
at even more affordable prices
and through various devices in your daily life
to bring you the best music anytime, anywhere
We use the Google Play platform
to develop many new technologies
and earned many accolades
In 2015,
we received Google Play "Best Apps of 2015" award
In 2016,
we received Google Play "Top Trending App"
and "Most Entertaining App" awards
Currently, over half of KKBOX active listeners
are Android users
Therefore Android has always been
an important development focus for us
Whether it’s Android TV, Chromecast
or Android Auto
or even the wearable Android Wear
we are fully committed to product R&D
so that listeners can enjoy the best cross-platform music experience
through these devices on our music service
In May of 2016
we started using Google Play In-app Billing.
This payment method
allows our members
to complete the payment process
in just a few simple steps
Paired with customized messages
it can effectively increase user’s willingness to buy
Compared with other payment methods
users can decide to make purchase quicker,
taking approximately 50% less time.
and it can also help speed up
KKBOX buyer conversion
We anticipate there will be more development in this area
In 2009, we entered the international market
by launching our services in Hong Kong
Japan, and South East Asia
Through IAB (Google Play In-app Billing)
It has given us more flexibility
in global commerce operations
KKBOX will continue to enhance
its products through content, features
and platform technologies
Our partnership with Google Play
also enables us to provide advanced
and convenient services
to integrate with the entire music industry ecosystem
so that we can provide a more exciting
and richer experience
to music lovers around the world